hello everyone and welcome back to the
chess 24 legends of chess tournament
it's another clash we've been waiting
for magnus carlson takes on the legend
himself uh peter leko
and this is the fourth game of the match
the first three games ended in a draw
even though uh leko had uh his fair ch a
fair share of chances
in taking down magnus uh so now magnus
with the white pieces
whoever wins it wins the match uh
otherwise we go into armageddon
uh so magnus with the white pieces opens
with c4
and i would just like to mention uh hugo
released a new song and today is also
judith polgar's birthday
so if you want to check it out it's
actually you did who stars uh
in the video uh the link will be the
first thing you see in the description
below so do check it out
now uh lekko replies with c5 uh we have
knight to c3 and the knight the c6 so
going for the symmetrical english
we have e3 and knight to f6 uh
magnus strikes in the center we have d4
captures captures
and d5 now with knight to f3 and
bishop to g4 so fairly symmetrical stuff
we have bishop to g5
and now e6 uh we have c captures on d5
you want to develop your bishop to d3
but then you have to waste the tempo if
black captures here then you recapture
and so on so that white will almost
always capture on the e5 here so e
captures and the bishop on d3 now
sorry another bishop and e3 bishop on e2
now uh
not allowing uh this pin to exist
uh you could go to the three magnus
decides to go for a bishop to e2 so we
have bishop to e7
uh and now comes uh castles by both
players so
uh sorry castles castles uh and now uh
there is one position in the database
where rook to e1 was played but here we
have
h3 by magnus and it is as of move 11
that we have a completely new game
so bishop back to h5 and now rook to e1
we have h6 challenging uh carlsen's dark
square bishop bishop to h4
and now rook the c8 and now uh apologies
to to everyone
with ocd magnus did not go for rook to
c1 but instead he went for
knight to e1 he offers a trade of light
square bishops here
and uh well asks uh wha what are you
what are you planning here so here
bishop captures on e2 by lekko and you
cannot capture with the queen because of
this knight captures here so rook
captures an e2
and now g5 uh pushing the bishop back
you want to
gain control of this e4 square without
trading off the dark square bishop so
bishop to g3
and now bishop to b4 lyco wants to trade
here on c3 and then get his knight over
to e4 and that will be an excellent
outpost for the knight
and both players are doing well on time
both players are above 10 minutes on the
clock here
so rook to c1 by magnus and now bishop
captures on c3
rook captures end knight to e4 now
attacking the rook here and magnus
goes rook c to c2 and we get this uh
very weird setup
with the queen and the two rooks here
not something you will see very often
uh rook to e8 by lekko and now uh magnus
goes for
knight captures on c6 rook captures uh
and rook characters on c6 with b
captures
and just bishop to h2 magnus doesn't
want to allow this trait he wants to
preserve his dark square bishop
as it is uh controlling a lot of a lot
of very important squares here on the
board
and here is the moment where we reach
the position from the thumbnail
basically
uh lekko should just do anything other
than the move he played so here
knight f6 and you offer a rook trade
let's say this happens
and you play the end game you are you
are very happy here
uh on the other hand you could also try
some other queen moves queen d7 queen b6
uh
anything really however rook the e6 by
lekko
uh probably comes with the idea of
doubling on the e file but it allows the
magnets to completely change the pawn
structure and
gain some activity so here magnus
challenges the knight with e3 right away
now you have to move the knight there
are no squares where you can move the
knights to defend the rook here
so knight back to d6 and now we have a
trade here rook captures f
captures and now uh queen to a4 by
magnus and here
uh magnus was up on time some six
minutes to four minutes and this comes
with a
uh with a triple threat here the c6 pawn
is under attack the a7 pawn and also the
knight is under attack here
so lekko has to position the queen to uh
deal with all three uh
three threats so here we have uh queen
to d7 now defending everything and now
queen before putting pressure
on the knight and again elekko has to
decide what to do here how to
save the knight so you could go
something like knight f7 knight to f5 or
something like uh
knight sorry knight to b7 knight to b5
so you have to choose something lego
decides to go for knight to c8
knight to f7 was also a possibility
maybe a better one
as with this knight the c8 move uh
magnus goes for the immediate queen to
b8 and now
it's very hard for black to find a move
of course the knight is now pinned
so king f7 unpinning but now bishop to
e5
and um it's just very hard uh
one of the things uh yeah why leko went
to knight's
knight here instead of for example
knight to f7 in that position for
example if knight to f7
uh then it's uh very hard to say where
this knight is going afterwards uh
these scores are covered the bishop
covers d square so the knight will
pretty much remain there forever uh so
after this queen to be for move knight
to c8 like we mentioned
and uh queen to b8 and now lekko has to
decide
he unpins here and now bishop to e5 uh
king to g8 leko is now forced to repeat
moves back and forth
not like that but like this and just
wait to see what magnus
will do and now it's um it's either one
of those positions where you can
improve improve improve improve to the
point where you've improved
enough to actually convert into a win or
it's one of those positions where black
is helpless
and you can improve all you want but you
still will not uh
gain enough enough improvement to
actually convert this into a win
so magnus starts with b4 uh and okay
king f7 lego repeats moves and now a4
and the problem for lako is also that
he's very low on the clock magnus is 4
minutes 30 seconds and lekko is down to
one minute
so king e7 and now a5 by magnus with
king to d8 and now
a6 uh lekko goes back king to e8 and now
king to h2 magnus starts bringing the
king into the game
king to f7 and now queen to b7 magnus
offers a trait here of course you cannot
trade because then there's no stopping
uh promotion
so after queen b7 we have kinked e8
defending the queen
and now g4 by magnus uh
there's actually a very interesting move
here that
i might even ask you to pause the video
and spot
uh and i will uh feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the
the sneakiest possible move that wins
for white
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting that you
have a dark square bishop and those
juicy points are all placed on dark
squares and for those who just want to
enjoy the show
bishop to g7 is is beautifully winning
because now there is not much you can do
of course you cannot capture the bishop
is also defended by the white queen
and well those pawns are coming off if
you start pushing them just bishop f6
you win this one
and then then you can just trade queens
and you have like a three to one
advantage here it's a
very straightforward win however magnus
decided to go for a different one and
this just
shows how much magnus understands the
end game uh
magnus goes for g4 here and we have
knight to e7 by lego tries to get the
knight into the game somehow now that
magnus weakened some squares here maybe
this will be possible
but queen the b8 check right away and
now uh
leko goes back knight to c8 and now king
the g3 improving the position of the
king even further
king to d8 and now again queen to b7
now uh that the knight is unpinned like
who goes knight to d6
uh but now uh comes uh comes through the
idea of of carlson playing g4 and
bringing the king over to g3
now magnus just trades off everything
and it was interesting during the live
commentary everyone was like how do you
win this how do you improve how do you
do
this and that's this and that but magnus
just uh trades into a king and pawn end
game just captures captures captures and
captures so you had all this activity
and you used it to bring your pawn to b4
to constrict
black from reaching c5 you have your
pass not a pass but upon all the way to
a6
and you have a three to two advantage
here which magnus will now use he plays
f4 and now king e7 and now comes h4
the only winning move that assures you
the creation of a past pawn
uh or if black captures it then your
king just enters the game
so king of six and now comes h captures
on g5
h captures f characters king captures
and now
uh the material on the board is equal
however magnus has the only winning move
again king f3 which allows you to
prevent black from reaching opposition
the the pawn prevents that so the black
king has to move king g6 and now you
gain the f4 square for your king king f6
now leko gains the opposition but it is
of little worth as
magnus can kick him away from there with
the g5 so king g6 and now king the e5
and here of course it is completely
winning now
lego captured we have captures uh king
f4 king d6 we have here
captures captures on d4 and now just b5
and it was in this position after
pushing b5
on move 52 that peter lecko resigned the
game and
what a victory for magnus carlsen in
game four of the match so
again a match is one without even going
into armageddon
so for the third match in a row magnus
grabs the full
three points and here you resign because
your pawns are much
faster for example if he moves you're
just going to play b6 sacrifice this
pawn and now the a7 pawn queens
there is nothing you can do about this
even if you start pushing
the pawns are too slow like in anything
you do here
the queen guards the d1 square so it's
it it's not any
it's not a problem and if you play
something like
king to d2 to maybe uh hide the the king
you know that uh we we discussed plenty
of times
which pawns are winning pawns which
pawns are drawing pawns and
this is definitely a winning pawn for
the side with the queen
so there there are no issues here so
after b5 loco resigns and an excellent
victory for magnus
so yeah that's uh the game i do hope you
enjoyed it do check out who a song the
link is in the description below
features judith polgar so do check it
out it is her birthday uh i would like
to thank bryce foster
ross martin michael pilgaard adam
nicholas and simon heath for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate
it as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
legends of chess on chess 24 tournament
uh checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
if you're
watching this immediately i'm also
streaming some chess with
hikaru levy and eric rosen on twitch so
do check it out if you guys are
interested in that
see you soon